[Music]
man why didn't they do a survivor spoof
while they were at it overdue doctor who
reviewed time and we are up to well I
thought we were up to the finale cuz
normally I do two parters as a single
story it's basically what I do whenever
I'm not reviewing the episodes as they
come out on a weekly basis it's how I
reviewed empty child and the doctor
dances it's how I've lumped things
together when I've done lists before
that's pretty much how I always do it
and that was my intention
coming into this however having now
watched both halves of this I know I
need to split these up because if I
don't I'm gonna talk about them as such
completely separate entities anyway
that's just gonna result in a double
length or a view that it would be more
easily digestible as two things because
honestly this is such a completely
different beast from the parting of ways
for about 80% of it like the tail end of
it dubs two dovetails into the into the
next one but what's going on up to that
point like bears no resemblance like it
hasn't almost no immediate bearing
whatsoever plot wise it just kind of
wastes time for 40 minutes and then I
say 40 minutes about 30 and then on top
of that totally it's completely out of
whack so you may have guessed from my
tone I don't really like a bad wolf
I've never liked bad wolf I didn't like
it at the time I didn't like I didn't
like the what I say at the time I didn't
watch it when it first aired but I
didn't like it at the time I actually
saw it for the first time which was
before all of these spoofs and parodies
and references became painfully dated I
didn't like them when they were relevant
I liked them even less now and
yeah so let's get into this we've got
this entire that we've got so much time
sunk into these topical TV show parodies
of Big Brother the weakest link and I
guess it's a British version of what not
to wear or some equivalent of that I
just why like why well why would anyone
think that this is worth more than five
minutes tops of the runtime to your
penultimate episode of your first series
like these are not biting observations
especially the way that the that the
climax in this episode Trump's all of
that it has no relevance to anything
that happens in the last 10 minutes it
was just a way to fill the time until we
got to there so like look if then we're
gonna legitimately try and do some sort
of parody where there were where they
came to a future or world or whatever
where there were there were game shows
where the prizes we don't kill you there
is some possibility in that as a initial
starting concept tying it to specific at
the time relevant TV shows was the first
mistake
using it to pad out something because
what you needed to do to set up the
following episode didn't build a
complete episode in and of itself so you
needed to Pat it out just sinks the
entire friggin thing I don't find these
funny maybe it's because I don't like
any of the shows that parody maybe if I
did maybe I'd get more entertainment out
of it but I just it is so great and even
if even if like I didn't hate it in and
of itself it just drags on so long
because we get established relatively
early through roses in the weakest link
thing that these are deadly games
because one of the other contestants
they are getting
that by the Droid and yet we still go
through a prolonged thing works like
it's another five minutes after that
before the doctor sees that these games
are deadly and it's another few minutes
after that that Jack realizes he's in
danger Yuri it's like it gets
established with ROS but then they spend
all this unnecessary time reestablishing
it again for each of the other two
characters why as an audience we are
immediately making the leap oh they're
all in danger
and then we're waiting for the heroes to
catch up which is never a good way to
tell a story you should not be waiting
for your heroes to realize what you
already know first for multiple scenes
it can work for tension building in a
single scene if like there's a bomb that
the other people in the room don't know
about you can build tension around that
but if you're just waiting for them to
figure something out that you already
know that's that's not tension that's
that's boredom and aggravation in my
case so there's all of that going on it
is such a total waste of Patterson
Joseph who is a wonderful actor and
honestly I've given up at this point he
was actor for for a very long time I
wanted to take over for the doctor I
wanted him to come in after Tennant and
play the doctor and if you if you don't
think that he would work in that part
then you need to go see the Neverwhere
miniseries which is not great production
values are kind of crap but there's some
highlights and he is one of them and
he's awesome in that I can totally see
him being the doctor and he's here
wasted as this jerk kokin contestant
alongside rose for the weakest link and
and then what happens to him in the next
episode which I'm wanting to get to
specifically they probably will forget
to mention when I reviewed that episode
doesn't pay off or make that satisfying
what a waste of a great actor now not
all of the supporting cast and this is a
waste Linda with a why I actually quite
like her I like the the dynamic that she
gets going with Eccleston pretty much
off the bat I like that she's you know
kind of nice kind of curious kind that
she he kind of likes a spark of hope in
her that she liked was probably
a little bit more of a dying ember that
she had before but you know she's like
oh like things can be good and fun and
not afraid I'm about to die huh yeah
that doesn't last you long because then
we have the threat of the Daleks now but
I like showing up the reveal in and of
itself is good or it would be if not for
one thing which is strictly speaking out
the vods of this episode but I need to
bring it up anyway because one of the
funny things about watching these is
that when you watch these however you
are doing it whether it's on a streaming
service or on the DVDs or what-have-you
they still have the next time on Doctor
Who because those were actually built
into the episodes to come in before the
credits started most of the time and so
as a result they blew the Dalek reveal
in the next time on Doctor Who segment
at the end of the previous episode so
look doctor who has a fairly decent
history at this point I say decent in
terms of decent amount not decent like
it's a decent thing of blowing its own
surprises I mean just been just but in
fact that the announcement of a new
doctor they make a big deal out of it
instead of surprising us with it speaks
to that but I said before that
logistically sometimes they don't really
have a choice because you know they new
people are gonna be on set like things
leaked everyone that has a has a has a
phone with a camera on it in their
pockets so it's harder to keep on top of
stuff but back when this was done there
was no excuse for that
absolutely none its job it's infuriating
because the episode itself is built on
the assumption that you don't know that
the Daleks are behind this it's very
clearly structurally supposed to be a
surprise and it's not at all because
they blew it if I set aside the fact
that that happened yes as a revealing of
itself works pretty decently and it's a
nice
build because you know we had
established in the episode Dalek how
dangerous these things are and then we
get you know boy one of these was really
that was a big problem now there's an
army of them
oh crap that is pretty solid escalation
as far as these things go so that works
I mean the dynamic between the you know
between the main cast the doctor and and
Jack Ambrose that works that's fine and
you know the I I really do like
Eccleston's no I'd like once the Daleks
get revealed the tail end of this
episode is really solid stuff and it's
good setup for what comes at the end I
love his no I love his just taking that
stand although I will say and this is ty
this is bringing up a little bit no I
guess it doesn't really feed too much in
the next episode but it is slightly
weird to me that so back in Dalek the
doctors anger that was sparked at seeing
a live Dalek and that he kind of just
spat venom at this thing you know
yelling at it why don't you just die and
it's odd to me that that instinct and
those emotions in that episode were
played as his damage and were played as
signs of issues and problems and things
that he's got to deal with because this
is not good that he's like this but here
you know coming off the no I said no you
know I'll tell you what I'm gonna do
he ends that with I'm gonna wipe every
last stinking Dalek out of the sky and
it's weird to me that he's tapping into
that anger again but here it's played as
cathartic and rousing that there's an
odd disconnect there that to be fair
only exists if you've kind of binge
through the season like I have
so it's it's not again not necessarily a
big fault of the episode but it is odd
to me that they have him have that
specific line where up up until then I
think it was played a little bit more
muted which I really like like highly I
love that the dogs are like you have no
resources no plan and he's just like
yeah doesn't that scare you to death I
was great in this you know when I talk
about there being that weird disconnect
in terms of that the anger being played
for catharsis here that's nothing about
his performance that's a choice of the
editing in the way the scene is built
with music and and presented that speaks
nothing to his performance which is
great he is he is really really good in
this as he's been through the vast
majority of this series so yeah the
reason I had to talk about bad wolf has
a separate thing instead of talking
about it and the parting of ways as a
single entity is that I just I have so
much hatred and bile about the how not
not only the mere existence of the game
show parodies but how much time is sunk
into them and ultimately how pointless
they are it just it drives me up the
wall and that is such a big chunk of
this episode that is the majority of the
runtime of this episode I don't feel
right complaining about that and then
having to try and thread the needle of
going from that to talking about the
next episode it just my brain can't make
that gear shift not in a single video so
that's why I'm breaking up and doing
these two things so bad wolf next week
we'll be parting of ways which i've had
to reorient my entire playing schedule
over this now but yes
bad wolf what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff you
can do because there's buttons and
there's links so you can like and
subscribe or you know follow a link to
the patreon if you are feeling oh so
very generous but you know what if
you're not don't even sweat it cuz
there's other links you can check out if
you feel like it but don't feel any
sure because at the end of the day you
guys are the council and I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]